cergy pontoise à son personnel un
questionnaire que vous on va voir dans
un instant pour officiellement et d
alerter sur d'éventuels comportements de
radicalisation alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut y lire
il ya plusieurs items qui sont
considérés comme signe d'appartenance
par exemple à apparence physique est ce
que vous avez constaté un changement de
tenue vestimentaire pour un homme le
port d'une gêne à bas ou le port d'un
pantalon dans les jambes s'arrêtent à
mi-mollet
dans l'arrêt d'autres items la
réintégration ou la réappropriation dans
une pratique religieuse par exemple
l'arrêt de consommation de boissons
alcoolisées l'arrêt soudain de
consommation de nourriture à base de
porc et puis alors ensuite défense de
nouvelles convictions et l' intérêt
soudain pour à l'actualité nationale et
internationale intérêt soudain pour la
religion
changement de discours au discours
prosélyte devant le tollé que cela a
suscité une université de cergy-pontoise
a fait un tweet pour s'excuser elle a
retiré le dcu le document est elle
s'excuse je cite d'avoir heurté ou
choquer certaines personnes
est-ce que vous avez été heurtée est-ce
que vous avez été choqué mon chat
christophe je suis lancé dans cette
affaire je crois que les signaux faibles
personne ne sait ce que c'est ce que la
barbe 2000 ils viennent et suspecte ou
ne l'est pas alors questionnaire non le
nist vincent couture et le verbe plus
court donc il est moins musulmans non
d'une part c'est c'est très peu clair
d'autre part c'est impraticable comme on
vient de le voir parce que dès qu'il y
aura ce genre de signalements il y aura
un tollé général
et surtout je l'avais déjà dit sur ce
plateau daianu on avait une
contradiction totale sur la question de
la fameuse vigilance
c'est dangereux si vous repérez et si
vous signaler c'est dangereux pour une
raison très simple ou une double raisons
la première c'est que gilles vous
signaler je signale que vous donnez
votre nom et votre adresse
deuxièmement et on a des cas tous les
jours si vous signalez vous risquez
d'être attaqué en diffamation et vous
aurez contre vous très probablement le
parquet donc on l'a vu dans x affaire
donc
dans cette affaire je dirais que
visiblement questions d'ordre public
hélas le libéral que je suis au sens
vraiment philosophique du terme dit
ceci est de la responsabilité de l'état
c'est bien la première des libertés
garanties par le libéralisme la sécurité
dans cette affaire c'est impraticable
c'est peu claires et c'est dangereux
pour ceux qui ferait des signalements
l'a bien vu regardez les autorités
cergy-pontoise sont mises en cause et je
suis pas certain qu'il n'y aura pas un
dépôt de plainte contre l'université
attendons de voir deux nuls
je pense qu'on que comme on a été
extrêmement on était extrêmement que mon
dirige faible dans la riposte collective
républicaine à la montée de l'islamisme
radical de crainte légitime de se faire
accuser de racisme de discrimination à
l'égard d'une partie de nos compatriotes
de gens qui vivent tout à fait
légitimement sur notre sol sous ce terme
qui a surgi d'islamophobie qui vous
retient de toute remarque est donc comme
on est collectivement faible qu'on a
peur de se faire à kaboul avait accusé
terroriser mais pas terrorisés pour des
raisons physiques un timide et
intellectuellement à l'idée de dire les
choses comme elles sont de dire moi par
exemple je considère je pense que là
le droit français rôle donne la liberté
de porter le voile
moi je considère que la discrimination
entre les hommes et les femmes est une
atteinte aux droits fondamentaux de la
république donc sage et j'estime a le
droit de le dire si on avait été plus
courageux collectivement dans la
dénonciation des mets des méfaits de
l'islamisme dont j'aurai je précise
d'ailleurs qu'il est d'abord nuisible
pour une partie large de la communauté
musulmane qui vit en france puisque
d'après les sondages
30% des mines et des musulmans déclare
que 27% que la loi religieuse est
supérieure à celle de la publiques ça
veut dire que 70 % d'entre eux
considèrent que celle inverse
et donc ces îles sont les premières
victimes eux ceux de nos compatriotes
qui quoique pratiquant l'islam le
considère comme parfaitement compatibles
avec les lois de la république et les
respecte sont les premières victimes des
excès d'une fraction radicaliser et qui
elle est en rupture de ban avec la
république donc si on était plus ferme
de manière générale avec ce danger on
aurait moins peut-être à se poser de
questions de cette nature c'est vrai que
envoyé des questionnaires pour repérer
c'est quand même dangereux parce qu'il
peut y avoir parmi ceux là des gens qui
par ailleurs pratiquent un islam
fondamentale censée être menaçants pour
la république donc ça m'inquiète
les signaux faibles quelle blague on
peut en voir partout je trouve ce qu'est
ce que nous dit citoyen parleurs ça doit
être le cousin de citoyens payeurs ça ça
vous me répondez sur sur le tchat
babineau nous dit je trouve ce
questionnaire très maladroit ce n'est
pas aux citoyens lambda de dénicher des
potentiels terroristes
est ce que c'est votre point de vue je
ne sais pas son rôle on peut pas ne pas
penser à l affaire des fiches vous savez
la république au début du siècle 1900 et
1904 avait ficher tous les officiers de
l'armée française qui était catholique
et y avait marqué par exemple vlm va à
la messe vlm avec un livre on va à la
messe avec un livre a assisté à la
première communion de sa fille etc et
s'était même pas de la radicalisation
c'était juste aller à la messe
et c'était extrêmement extrêmement
commandes excellent livre de jean cia
connaît maintenant les catholiques
étaient hors la loi
non mais ça et quand on voit souvent
absente chez dell avec laquelle la
communauté musulmane
enfin certains monde à communauté
musulmane dénonce une islamophobie
d'état on a envie de leur rappeler ses
précédents historiques mais montrer que
les catholiques aussi ont souffert d'un
république des choses bien plus salée
congrégation et c'est qu'aujourd'hui
après je trouve ça extrêmement maladroit
parce que il sait aussi une forme de
démission l'état qui en effet ce se
demande aux citoyens de faire de faire
son travail et je le dis souvent on a le
signalement c'est que les gens se
radicaliser pour nous michael harpon par
exemple il y avait eu il avait été déjà
fiché enfin signalé est donc le problème
c'est une fois que la signalisation
également été fait qu'est ce qu'on fait
quelles sont les conséquences du signal
politique mon avis c'est ça le vrai
sujet
xavier
si vous partagez pas
le point de vue qui vient d'être
unanimement exprimé vous me le dites
et sinon je passe à la deuxième question
le point du fait qu'il y ait ni mort je
dirais simplement que on entre si l'on
se laisse aller à ce genre de pratique
dans un dans une atmosphère de délation
qui est quand même propre à l'histoire
de france et qui a marqué notre notre
parcours histoire sombre de voler son
delà de la république de la terreur à le
chat joue très simplement quand on
parlait c'est quoi un signal faible
il ya suffisamment de signes de signaux
forts pour que l'état qui à l'arsenal
nécessaire traite les signaux forts même
page et c'est en plein ce signal fort
bien tenir et on a par am rcd j'ajoute
j'ajoute que vous parlez tout à l'homme
nos amis kurdes qui se sont lâchés et
qui vont peut-être mettre dans la nature
un certain nombre de porteurs de ces
niveaux très très fort il faut qu'on
serait bien de bien heureux de contrôler
dès aujourd'hui alors bon moi j'ai
entendu votre
votre votre condamnation vous est
peut-être donner un début de réponse
xavier parce que la question c'est pour
ça qu'on leur posait aujourd'hui c'est
comment on détecte sans faire de dénis
islamisme comme disait alexis boisés ou
comment on alerte sans faire de la
délation de la parra mais justement ces
problèmes et la question est ce que
c'est vraiment celle de l' alerte quand
on a chaque fois que très souvent quand
quelqu'un a fait un inventaire
on avait déjà des signalements savez
qu'il est radicalisé leur chez-soi sujet
moi je pense que c'est le problème c'est
que quand on alerte quand on voit et
qu'il était rien d l'imam de gonesse ont
j'en parlais il a dit publiquement qu'il
n'était pas charlie il a été l'objet
d'une expulsion et cette expulsion n'a
pas été menée en boubou moi je pense que
le problème est politique c'est pourquoi
une fois qu'on alerte des décisions ne
sont pas prises c'est pas la question
d'aller à l'alerté les la donne et je
crois qu'il faudrait qu'on arrive qu'on
parvienne pas facile je c'est un voeu
pieux mais qu'on parvienne à exprimer
collectivement le souhait que les
valeurs de la république de manière non
agressive non discriminatoires non
racistes à l'égard de ceux de nos
compatriotes qui pratiquent l'islam il
faudrait qu'on arrive à dire cependant
publiquement et collectivement que nous
sommes que la république française que
que nos valeurs sont hostiles à un
certain nombre des traits
caractéristiques de la parti radical de
cet islam et qui est incompatible avec
les valeurs de la république il faut
qu'on le répète collectivement d'une
manière calme et quand ce travail sur
les mentalités aura été fait sur
l'expression publique
ce sera peut-être plus simple déjà ça
permettra à ceux de nos compatriotes qui
sont musulmans mais qui ne partagent pas
du tout
cet islamisme radical de pouvoir
l'assumer aujourd'hui ils craignent
d'être des jaunes de dénoncer de charme
aimerait que les musulmans pacifiques
s'exprime davantage oui mais mais comme
comme ils sont pris dans un que dans une
attaque dont il pense qu'elle est
qu'elle est raciste et ils se disent je
ne vais pas je ne vais pas participé à
une attaque raciste ou une attaque
discriminatoire donc si on était capable
d'exprimer de manière calme positive et
ouverte le fait qu'on accepte
parfaitement la pratique de la religion
en france qu'elles soient islamique
qu'elle soit musulmane catholique juif
protestant ou de quelque nature qu'elles
soient dès lors qu'elle est compatible
avec les lois de la république et
qu'elle l'erreur connais je crois qu'on
aurait fait un grand pas il mais ça ça
me parait trans partisan transcourants
et devant faire l'objet d'un consensus
fondamental des 70% en parlais tout à
l'heure denis 70% des musulmans qui se
sentent ville dans une république dont
ledroit s'exprime et s'exerce pleinement
pour leur vie quotidienne
la religion étant vécue en parallèle
mais dans le respect du droit ne le
respect de la république ne les âmes non
pas à remettre cette conviction en cause
et c'est justement dans la chasse aux
signaux faibles
la désignation d'un ennemi qui veut une
sorte de brouillard dans une brume
bizarroïdes
c'est là que l'on fabrique des
hostilités chez les générations qui
viennent qui sont qui se succèdent et
qui se disent dans le fond nous sommes
désignés du doigt quoi que nous fassions
oui moi je vais tout à fait dans le même
sens je crois quand même signaler que
cette proportion justin pour les faits
avec cette proportion un peu un peu
radical est morte ce qu'elle est surtout
très forte chez les jeunes où on
approche les 50 % là donc il faut il
faut faire un petit peu attention et
d'autre part je suis en plein accord
avec avec c'est avec ce qu'a dit denis
olivennes mais à l'homme des médias je
pose la question les trois quarts je
suis généreux des médias français ou aux
universitaires français dont je suis des
trois quarts deux universitaires et
trois quarts des médias disent le
contraire de ce que vous dites c'est à
dire tiennent un discours de
complaisance vis-à-vis de l'islam
radical
il faut quand même il faut quand même le
dire c'est à dire qu'on a des secours de
complaisance relate discours du tout
mais par exo peur justement où en est on
vega pour les accusations du slow food
ans et des fesses de fiches de films et
on mélange des choses qui sont anodines
avec des choses très très grave rien ne
pas serrer la main d'une femme dans un
service public quelqu'un qui ne serre
pas la main d'une femme
moi je trouve sa problématique est en
effet là vous prend des mesures je ne
peux pas tolérer que par exemple un
conducteur de bus ratp refuse de parler
aux parler aux femmes par exemple ça
c'est intolérable et la prenons des
mesures parce que ces gens là on les
connaît ils sont identifiés ça se sait
dans les services mais on ne fait rien
là je pense que et ont plutôt se mettre
d'accord pour dire que c'est un progrès
parce que c'est le suivi qui est
abandonnée dont encore une fois c'est le
rôle des entreprises notamment des
entreprises publiques et de l'état qui
se défausse un peu facilement et bons
rapports vous dire qui est quand même
très inquiétant qui montrent
effectivement la montée de l'islamisme
radical dans les services publics ça
évidemment cette mission parlementaire
il faut la lire dans le détail elle est
quand même assez inquiétant et les
mesures qu'ils qui avait été préconisée
qui n'ont pas toujours été prises
derrière et c'est une émission
d'ailleurs que l'on avait fait
spécifiquement sur la question qui est à
retrouver sur la page décrypteur de
figaro live selon vous est il possible
de repérer en amont les potentiels
terroristes ces questions que vous posez
sur twitter hashtag figure live hashtag
décrypteurs vous répondez oui à 57 % non
à cornes 3% et effectivement le seul le
débat nous a permis de voir combien
c'était délicat et de voir justement sur
les critères qu'il était important
d'abord de se mettre d'accord avant de
pouvoir
mener une réflexion sur ces questions là